What I would like to do in this presentation is to prove one of the most
The results are useful in geometry, namely the peripheral angle
It is a corner whose head is located on an ocean
Circle
This is the peripheral angle
I'll call it psi - I use the psi name for the peripheral angle
The angles in the display
psi, or peripheral angle, equals exactly 1/2
Corner center which has the same arch
I have used many good words, but I think you
You know what I say
If this is PSI
An oceanic angle
Located, its view is located on the perimeter of the circle
If you draw the two rays that come from this angle
Or Vetrin who knew this corner, will intersect
Circle from the other end
If you look at the part of the circumference of the circle where the circle is located
Inside it, this is the bow that
Compiled by psi
They are all excellent words, but I think the idea
Quite directly
This is an arc that is contained by psi, where the psi is
That corner is here, and the head is located
On the perimeter of the circle
Now, the central corner of the corner neighborhood where the head is
Located on the center of the circle
I suppose this is - I'm trying to tell it -
Here is the center of the circle
Let me draw a central angle that includes this same arch
It looks like a central angle that has the same arch
So
Let's call it Theta
This angle is psi, and this angle is theta
What I will prove in this presentation is that PSI is always
Equal to 1/2 theta
If I wanted to tell you that PSI is equal, I do not know
25 degrees, so you will quickly know that theta
Must be equal to 50 degrees
Or if I tell you that theta is measured 80 degrees, you'll
You know directly that the PSI measurement is 40 degrees
Let us prove this
Let me erase this
And a good place to start, or where
I will start with it, a special case
I will draw a peripheral angle, but one of the strings
You know it will be circle diameter
This will not be the general situation, it will be
Special case
Let me see, this is the center of the circle
I try to catch it
The center looks like this
Let me draw a diameter
If the diameter looks like this
Then let me know the peripheral corner
This diameter is considered one of the ribs
Then the other side may look like this
Let me name this psi
If the PSI, this length is a radius - that is
Radius of the circle
Then this length will be radius
The circle that moves from the center of the ocean
The ocean is defined by all points
A distance equal to the radius of the center
If this is also a radius
Now, this isosceles triangle
He has two equal ribs
Two equal ribs
We know that when we have two equal ribs
The corners of the base are equal
If this is also equal to PSI
Perhaps you will not realize it
So inclined
But I think many of us when we see a triangle seem
As such, if we assume that this is r and r, where are these two
The two sides are equal, if these are PSI
You will know that this angle is also PSI
The corners of the base are equal in the isosceles triangle
If these are PSI, those are also PSI
Now, let's look at the central corner
This central corner has the same arch
Let us look at the arch that surrounds it
This is the arc of the floodlight enclosing it
This is the central angle, ie theta
Now if this corner is theta, what will this angle be?
This angle
Well, this corner is complementary to Thita
That is measured by 180-theta
When you combine these two angles you will get 180 degrees
They will be a line
They are complementary to each other
Now we also know that these three angles are located
Inside the triangle itself
If their total must also be 180 degrees
We get psi -psi + these + psi ones + psi + these
Corner = 180 - Theta + 180 - Theta
These three angles must be a total of 180 degrees
They are the angles of the three triangle
Now we can ask 180 from both sides
psi + psi = 2psi, - theta = 0
We collect theta for both parties
We get 2psi = theta
Hit both sides with 1/2 or divide both ends on 2
We get a psi equal to 1/2 theta
So we have demonstrated what we wanted to prove
For the special case where the peripheral angle is defined, and where that is one of
Ray, if we want to consider these lines as rays, where one of the
The radiation that defines this peripheral angle is
Along the diameter
The diameter forms part of that beam
If this is a special case where one angle
Located on the diameter
And of course we can generalize this
Now that we know that if these are 50 these
It will be 100 degrees, is not it?
Whatever the measurement of PSI or whatever theta measurement, the PSI will be 1/2
So, whatever the measurement of PSI, FTATA will be
2 x so
This is applied at any time
We can use this theory at any time - using those
The result we'll get, we can now do it a bit
Although this does not apply to all peripheral angles
Let's draw an oceanic angle that looks like this
If this status, status, you can consider it
Inside the circle
This is the peripheral angle
I want to find a relationship between these
The peripheral angle and the central angle that includes
Same bow
This is the central corner that has the same arch
Well, you might say, none of these endings or these
The strings know the angle, and none of them crosses the diameter
But what can be done is that we can draw Qatar
If the center is located through these two poles
We can draw diameter
We can paint Qatar looks like this
If we draw a diameter it looks like this, if we know this angle
To be psi1, this angle is psi2
Clearly, psi equals the sum of these two angles
We call this theta angle 1, and these are theta 2
We will know this directly, using the result
I got it, since we have one side of the corners in both cases
It is a diameter now, we know that PSI1
= 1/2 theta 1
We know that psi2 equals 1/2 theta 2
psi2 equals 1/2 theta 2
If PSI, ie PSI1 + PSI2
They are equal
1/2 theta 1 + 1/2 theta 2
psi1 + psi2 = first peripheral angle
Which we want to deal with
This is psi
This equals 1/2 ×
Theta 1 + Theta 2
What is Total Theta 1 + Theta 2?
So it is worth the original thatta
We were dealing with it
Now we see that psi equals 1/2 theta
We have now proved it to be more general
Where the center is located within the two radii
They know that angle
Now, we have not yet identified a slightly more difficult situation or
The situation is more general where this status is
The circle and I have a peripheral angle and center is not
Located within the Altran
Let me paint it
This will be the head, and I will replace the colors
Let's assume that this is one of the strings that you know
The angle, so
Suppose that this other string is known
The angle is so
How can we find the relationship between, let's
We call, this corner, let's call it PSI1
How to find the relationship between psi1 and central angle
Which includes the same arch?
When I talk about the same bow that is here
If the central corner has the same arc
You will look like this
Let's call it Theta 1
What we can do is use what we learned when we rib off
The peripheral angle is the diameter
Let us create it
Let me paint a cat here
The result we want should be 1/2
But let's prove it
Let me draw a diameter like this
Let me name this corner, let me call it psi2
It includes this bow - let me draw it
In dark color
This bracket is included
If the central corner has the same arc
Let me call it Theta 2
Now, we know from the first part of the presentation that PSI2
Equals 1/2 theta 2, right?
They share - Qatar is here
The diameter is one of the tendons that form the angle
If psi2 equals 1/2 theta 2
That's exactly what we were doing at the last show, right?
This is an oceanic angle
One of the strings that defines falls on the diameter
This equals 1/2 this angle, ie the central angle
Which includes the same chord
Now, let's look at this larger corner
This corner is bigger
psi1 + psi2
True, the larger corner is psi1 + psi2
Again, it includes this whole arch, and
Where the diameter appears to be one of the strings that are known
This corner is huge
This is equal to the central half of that angle
It has the same arch
We use what we have explained in this offer
If this equals 1/2 this huge angle
Theta 1 + Theta 2
We used everything we learned
At the beginning of the presentation
Now, we already know that PSI2 equals 1/2 theta 2
Let me do this compensation
That's worth it
I can say that SI1 + - instead of SI2 I will write
1/2 Theta 2 is equal to 1/2 theta 1 + 1/2 theta 2
We can subtract 1/2 theta 2 from both ends, and
We get the result
si1 equals 1/2 theta 1
Now we are finished
We have shown the case where the peripheral angle is
1/2 central corner which has the same arch
Regardless of whether the center of the circuit is located inside
Corner, or outside the corner, or if we have
Qatar on one side
Any other angle can be a total
Any one or all we did
If I wish you found this useful and now we can already
Rely on this outcome until we do more
Engineering evidence